they finally did it the publication of
the ruling of the constitutional court
of poland and the support of the
polish government supposes the de facto prohibition
of abortion
coots odious harem that turns it
october sounds like a bronx listing today
prof
a whole band huawei deserves
water
but you have all  social security as
the cptm of a nation and howard spector
adherence man of vouchers of 32
fills with songs they speak in double the size of the
group right and commit
security council bet mother-in-law since
they put augur on abertis board that according
to ine statistics
they are futile they try to air close
to cristian's work on abortion
this article
is of great interest as beatles this
term multiplied for being a setback
because consul my habitat that bled
belgian jack frans the bloody the fight
of the election constants of this
innovative learning
programmed functions a single  indeed it is
to lower the arms covered by
these dates mie  ntras inem and finance and
organized and program of guardians in
sex education
rich product
sting we will talk once we will talk 5
we will talk as many times as necessary
you are not alone we are going to defend
all women in europe thank you very much